Transcriber: Nihal Aksakal
Gözden geçirme: Miraç Şendil
Şimdi ben gelecek mevzusuna
birazcık geçmişten başlayarak uzanacağım.
Çünkü biz genelde gelecek tasarımlarımız
ve beklentilerimiz söz konusu olduğunda
geleceğe, geçmişe atıflar yaparız.
Kimimiz bazı dezavantajlarla
geldik dünyaya,
kimimiz sonradan travmalar yaşadık
ve bazen gerçekten keşke geçmişi
değiştirebilsem dediğimiz olur
ya da keşke nokta nokta yapmasaydımla
başlayan cümleler kurarız
ve bazen 5-0 yenik durumdaymış
gibi gözükür hayatlarımız.
Peki geçmiş aynı kalırken, her şey,
çevremiz aynıyken, insanlar aynıyken,
hiçbir şey değişmiyorken,
gelecekle alakalı
daha ümitli olmak mümkün mü?
Daha iyi hissedebiliyor olmak
mümkün mü?
Genelde biz psikologlara
bu tarz sorular sorarlar.
Yani özellikle terapiye geldiklerinde
''Yani ne değişecek ki konuşarak?''
sorusunu aslında sık duyarız.
Her şey aynı, kocam aynı,
evliliğim aynı,
savaşlar aynı dünya aynı,
hiçbir şey değişmiyorken
benim olumlu hissetmem mümkün mü?
Şimdi aslında bu sorunun
kendisinde bir sıkıntı var.
Eskiden bu soruyu
cevaplamaya çalışıyordum
ama şimdi bu sorunun kendisinden
biraz şüphe ediyorum.
Çünkü aslında bu soru
bizim sağlık tanımlarımızın
tamamen olumlu hissetmekle
eşitlendiği anlamına geliyor.
Sanki iyi olma hali,
sağlıklı hissetme hali
pür olumlu hissetmekten geçiyor.
Oysaki bizim sağlıklı
ve sağlıksız acılar arasında
bir ayrım yapmamız lazım.
Sağlıklı acı denen şey
yaşamamız için gerekli.
Yaşamamız gereken durumlarda,
yaşamamız gereken düzeylerde
yaşanması gereken,
bizi hasta etmeyecek,
bizi olgunlaştıracak,
yaşamamıza bilgi ve tecrübe olarak
dönüşecek acılar aslında.
Bu anlamda acıların büyüklüğünün
ve küçüklüğünün çok da bir önemi yok.
Olayların büyüklüğünün
ya da küçüklüğünün çok da bir önemi yok.
Mesela kimi insanlar
anne kaybı yaşıyorlar.
Bu anne kaybında yasalarını tutuyorlar
ve o yasın sonrasından güçlenerek
ve daha bilge, daha tecrübeli insanlar
olarak çıkıyorlar.
Kimileri abartmıyorum, gerçek
örneklerden vermeye çalışıyorum.
Bileziğini kaybediyor,
onu takıntı haline getiriyor.
Bir türlü yediremiyor kendisine
kaybettiği bir şeyi geri bulamamayı
ve onu aslında psikolojik
bir gerilemeye dönüştürüyor.
Dolayısıyla olayların büyüklüğü
küçüklüğü önemli değil,
belirleyici değil.
Bizim acıları nasıl yaşantıladığımız
önemli olan aslında.
Şimdi çoğu zaman, bazı insanlar
güçlüklerin altından
daha bilge ve daha tecrübeli
bir şekilde kalkıyorlar
ama bazı insanlar
o acıların altında eziliyor.
Benim çıkış noktam burada şu:
Ne oluyor da kederin yönü,
acının yönü bir şekilde değişiyor?
Niye birileri aynı acıların altından
güçlü binaları inşa ederek kalkarken
birileri de onu enkaza çeviriyor?
Nedir bunun yönünü belirleyen şey?
Ne zaman elmastan kömüre
dönüşüyor acılarımız?
Birazcık bununla alakalı
konuşalım istiyorum aslında.
Öncelikle bazı içsel engellerimizden
bahsetmekte fayda var.
Mesela iyi hissetme saplantımız var.
Koşulsuz şartsız aslında iyi
hissetmemiz gerektiğini düşünüyoruz.
Bu yüzden kederi çoğu zaman
içeri buyur etmeme eğilimimiz var.
Çoğu zaman, her zaman mutlu olmalıyım
şeklinde bir talepkârlığımız,
asla dayanamam şeklinde bir dayatmamız,
acıyı ötelemek isteyen bir zorbalığımız
eşlik ediyor hüzünlerimize
ve biz aslında acımız hakkında acı
mutsuzluğumuz hakkında mutsuzluk,
öfkemiz hakkında öfke duymaya
başlıyoruz.
Aslında duyguların karesini alıyoruz
ve organik olan sağlıklı acılar
toksiklenmeye başlıyor.
Gidici ve aslında üretici olan acılar
kalıcı ve tüketici olmaya başlıyor.
Bunların bir şekilde formunu
değiştiriyoruz.
Çoğumuz şimdi özellikle
şu son dönemlerde
mevcut sistemin içerisinde
boşluğu derhal dolduracak
hobileri arama peşindeyiz.
Can sıkıntısını hemen geçirecek eylemler,
kaderimize hemen pansuman olacak hazlar,
suçluluğumuzu hemen yatıştıracak
zalimler dışarıda buluyoruz.
Günahlarımızı hemen öteleyecek
meşruiyetler yaratıyoruz.
Yani duygularımızla bir şekilde
yüzleşmiyoruz.
Ne yetersiz yönlerimizle yüzleşmeye,
ne suskunluğun dönüştürücü kramplarına,
ne yalnızlığın doğurganlığına
yüz verdiğimiz yok.
Haksızmışım deyip onarmaktan,
suçluymuşum deyip değişmekten,
yanılmışım deyip düzeltmekten
çok korkuyoruz.
Oysa ki her duygu gerçekten birer aygıt.
Hepsi ruhumuzun inşası için gerekli olan,
besin değerleri olan şeyler.
Pastayı yiyerek büyüyemiyor insan.
Bizim bütün bu duygulara
oda açmamız lazım
kendi ruhsal sisteminizde.
Nasıl sadece belli aralıklarda
besinler tükettiğimiz de
bağışıklığımız zayıflıyorsa,
sadece belirli aralıklarla duyguları
hissetmeye çalışmak da
bizim topraklarımızı çoraklaştıracak
bir atmosfer oluşuyor.
Bu yüzden bizim çeşitli duyguları,
kendi iç dünyamızda ağırlamamız lazım.
Ancak o zaman geçmişin duygularıyla
geleceği daha bereketli
bir şekilde inşa edebiliriz,
o tohumlarla daha bereketli
bir toprak ekip biçebiliriz.
Şimdi bir farklı mesele de
mutlulukla olan ilişkimiz.
İyi hissetme saplantımız, takıntınız
birazcık da mutlulukla
kurduğumuz ilişkiden besleniyor.
Çünkü hepimizin kafasında
mutlulukla alakalı formüller var.
''Nokta noktaya sahip olursam
çok mutlu olacağım
veya nokta noktaya sahip olmazsam
çok mutlu olacağım''.
Sahip olmak üzerinden tanımlanan
mutluluk formülleri
gerçekten çok tehlikeli.
Çünkü sahip olmak üzerinden
kurguladığınız mutluluk,
ona ulaştığınızda, her ulaştığınız anda
kendini bir öteye çeken bir serap gibi,
onunla aranızdaki farkı
asla kapatamıyorsunuz.
O gedik, o açık asla kapanmıyor.
Hep bir daha fazlasına
ihtiyaç duyuyorsunuz.
Çünkü alışkanlık dediğimiz şey
bu hayatta her şeyi birbiriyle eşitliyor.
Bizim gözlerimiz suyun içindeyken suyu,
altının içindeyken altını
çok da fark edemeyecek
şekilde tasarlanmış.
Varlık denen şey mesafe istiyor
ve aşırı doygunluk istiyor
ve doyduğu şeyin kendi kendisini
imha etmesine neden oluyor.
Bu anlamda bizim bir araştırmaya
göz atmamız lazım.
Aslında geçmişle alakalı bir araştırmayı
size örnek verirsem belki
bunu destekleyen bir kanıt olacak.
Mesela piyango bileti kazananlar ile
yapılan bir araştırma var.
Çok yüklü miktarlarda
para kazanan insanlar
bir sene boyunca takip ediliyorlar.
Bir sene sonra ne hissettiklerine
bakılıyor.
Bu insanların aslında anlamlı bir şekilde
daha önceki hallerinden
daha mutsuz oldukları bulunuyor.
Onca sahip oldukları şeye rağmen,
sahip olmak üzerinden mutlu olma halini
ben matematiksel bir formülle
temsil ediyorum aslında.
Bir bölü iki.
Bir bölü ikide kalıyorsunuz her zaman.
Ne demek bu?
Paydada sahip olduklarınız olsun, iki,
payda sahip olmak istedikleriniz olsun,
bir.
Sahip olduklarımız dörde çıktığında
payda zaten ikiye çıkıyor.
Sahip olduklarınız sekize çıktığında
payda zaten dörde çıkıyor.
Oranınız hiçbir zaman değişmiyor.
Her zaman bir bölü ikidesiniz.
Bu anlamda hayatın çok adaletli
olduğunu düşünüyorum gerçekten.
Çünkü içsel huzur ve içsel tatmin duygusu
sahip olmak üzerinden değil,
tamamen olma hali üzerinden
bize bahşediliyor.
Çok kötü koşullarda
yaşayan insanlar tanıdım.
Çok fakirlerdi, çok kötü
koşullarda büyümüşlerdi
ama içsel huzurları vardı.
Gerçekten çok konforlu,
her imkana sahip insanlarla tanıştım,
içsel huzurları yoktu.
Çünkü onlar aslında sahip olmak üzerinden
hayatlarını bir şekilde
kurgulamaya çalışıyorlardı.
Şimdi geçmişin dezavantajlarını
geleceğin zenginliğine dönüştürmek,
bizim birazcık da acı ve mutlulukla
kurduğumuz ilişkiye bağlı aslında.
Geçmiş değişmez evet, olan oldu,
çocukluğunuz aynı, travmalarınız aynı,
kayıplarınız aynı,
yediğiniz kazıklar aynı.
Hiçbir şeyi değiştiremezsiniz
geçmişle alakalı.
Fakat geçmiş anılarınızı
değiştirebilirsiniz.
Araştırmalar da böyle söylüyor.
Çünkü bizim bellek dediğimiz şey,
anı dediğimiz şey aslında
donuk video kayıtları gibi değiller.
Bizim geçmişten geri getirdiğimiz
ve hiçbir değişikliğe uğratmadan
izlediğimiz kayıtlar değiller.
Geçmişe her hatırlamaya
çalıştığınızda şimdi ve burada
bugün onları yeniden inşa ediyorsunuz,
şeklini değiştiriyorsunuz,
formunu yeniden yapılandırıyorsunuz.
Dolayısıyla geçmişi geleceğe taşımak,
biraz da anılarınızı, bugünü nasıl
yeniden inşa ettiğinizle alakalı.
Travmayı dönüştürme meselesinde
ben bir hırsız metaforu kullanıyorum.
Özellikle bundan bahsetmek istiyorum.
Diyelim ki evinize bir hırsız
girdiğini düşünün.
Her şeyi çaldı, yağmaladı,
yangın çıkardı evinizde.
Evsiz barksız kaldınız.
Elbette hiçbir şey eskisi gibi olmaz.
Travmalar böyledir.
Eskisi gibi olmaz.
Mutlaka bazı taşlar yerinden oynar.
Fakat böyle bir travmadan sonra
insanlar genelde ikiye ayrılırlar.
Kimileri hırsıza ve hırsızlığa takılırlar.
Nefretle, öfkeyle.
Kimileri yaşamlarına kendilerini
onarmak üzerine devam ederler.
Nefrete takılanlar,
biz eğer nefrete takılıyorsak
bir travmadan sonra,
düşmanla uğraşıyorsak,
kendimizi onarmamız mümkün değil.
Çünkü nefretin olduğu iklimde
onarım olmaz.
Nefret, kin bizim hırsızla,
tramvayla olan göbek bağımızdır.
Travmanın suyudur.
Soygun olmuştur ama ruhumuzun soygunu
devam ediyordur.
Ancak ve ancak biz nefretin ve kinin
yapıştırıcı ve hatırlatıcı etkisinden
sıyrılabilirsek
o zaman yeni bir hayat kurgulamaya
başlayabiliriz.
Belki hiç aklımıza
gelmemiş olan dualar gelir,
hiç kurmadığımız hayalleri
kurmaya başlarız.
Hiç çalmadığımız kapıları çalmak
aklımıza gelir.
Ancak o zaman travmanın harabesinden,
şerri hayra çeviren
bir tılsım çıkartabiliriz.
O zaman içinde yeni
bir senle karşılaşabiliriz.
Onardıkça kendimizi tamir ettikçe,
düzelttikçe,
hırsızın çalışları azalır içimizde
ve soygun rızka dönüştüğünde
onun çaldıkları kazandıklarınız
yanında küçük kalır.
Şimdi her ne soyulduğu ise hayatımızda,
ne bozulduysa, ne kırıldıysa,
artık işimiz ne soygunla
ne de soyguncu ile olmalı.
Çünkü asıl travma dışarıda olanın
içeride devam etmesidir.
Yoksa dışarıda olup biten her şey
akıp gitmeye meyilli aslında.
3 tane önerim olacak.
Geçmişi geleceğe daha zenginleştirici
bir şekilde taşıyabilmemiz için.
Bir tanesi zihninizin
tutarlılığına çomak sokmaktır.
Ben çok seviyorum bu lafı.
Çünkü bizim zihnimiz
tutarlı olmak isteyen bir zihin
ve bu bazen bizim aleyhimize işliyor.
Birileri geçmişte bize öğretiyor,
sen yapamazsın, sen dayanamazsın
ve biz bunlarla büyüyoruz ve bunları
doğrularcasına aslında yaşıyoruz.
Zihnimiz böyle çalışıyor.
Mesela bir örnek vereyim size,
diyeyim ki size şu anda
burada bir hırsız var,
burada bir hırsız var
ve bu hırsızın mavi gömlekli
olduğunu söyleyeyim,
bıyıklı olduğunu söyleyeyim size.
Bununla alakalı bir eşkal vereyim.
Bundan sonra yapacağınız şey
otomatik olarak mavi gömlekli kişilerin
peşine daha fazla düşmek olacak.
Belki yanınızda hırsızlık
yapmak üzere olan
sarı gömlekli olan birini atlayacaksınız.
Şimdi sorun zihnimizin
eşkale göre çalışması değil aslında.
Sorun bu eşkalden hiçbir zaman
şüphe etmeyişimiz.
Çünkü bizim hayatımızda bizimle ilgili,
nasıl biri olduğumuzla alakalı verilmiş
yüzlerce eşkal var.
Sen yapamazsın, sen zayıfsın,
sen terk edilirsin, sen sevilmezsin,
sen başarılı olamazsın.
Bu eşkallerin hiçbirini
çoğumuz sorgulamıyoruz.
Bunları aleyhimize de olsa doğrularcasına
hareket ediyoruz aslında.
Ama ya eşkal yanlışsa?
Yani ya hırsız kıyafetini değiştirdiyse
ya ben size bunu yanlış verdiysem,
ya başka bir hırsız daha varsa?
Dolayısıyla geçmişini geleceğe farklı
ve daha zenginleştirici
bir şekilde taşıyanlar,
eşkâllerden şüphe edenler olacak.
Soru sorabilen, merak edebilen,
kendilerine öğretilenleri yıkıp
yeniden yazma cesareti
olabilenler olacak.
Eğer kendi iç dünyamızdaki
tutarlılık ve çatışmasızlığın
bir tık ötesine geçebilirsek,
birazcık araflarda kalma cesaretini
gösterebilirsek
o zaman biz de onlardan biri olabiliriz.
Yıkmak ve yeniden yapabilmek,
sınırlarımızı güncelleyebilmek için
zihnimizin tutarlılığına
çomak sokmaya ihtiyacımız var.
İkinci önerim linç etmeyip süblime etmek.
Süblimasyon lafını çok seviyorum.
Çünkü bizi insan yapan şey dönüştürmek.
Hepimiz travmalardan sonra,
kayıplardan sonra çok yoğun
duygular hissediyoruz.
Öfke hissediyoruz, nefret hissediyoruz.
Ama nefretin olduğu hiçbir ortamda
onarım olmaz.
Eğer nefret varsa bu
bir insanın psikolojik lincidir.
Bu sadece başkasının linçi değil,
bizim kendi bahçemize zulüm edişimizdir.
İnsan kötüsünü, katısını, yarasını,
nefretini, öfkesini
dönüştürdükçe insan olabilir.
Linç edenlere avcı,
dönüştürenlere sanatçı
diyebiliriz aslında.
Hepimizin ruhsal ekosisteminde haset var,
kötülük var, agresyon var, nefret var.
Bunları yok etmek değil,
bunları dönüştürmekle
insan olabileceğiz sadece.
Nefretin harlı ateşinden,
şefkatin kısık ateşine geçip
yanmaktan pişmeye evrilmezsek
hiçbir acımızı kendimizi
onaracak şekilde dönüştüremeyiz.
Son önerim.
Kötü olabilme cesareti göstermek.
Tırnak içinde kötü olabilme cesareti.
Şimdi sahip olma toplumunda,
gözükme toplumunda
erdemler de bundan payını aldı aslında.
Onlar da metaya dönüştü.
Biz bir şekilde erdemli gözükmek istiyoruz
ve bazen onun görüntüsüne
sahip olmak isterken içini boşaltıyoruz.
Bakın çevrenize mesela,
samimi gözükmek için
poz veren insanlar görebilir misiniz?
Veya dünyaya bakın.
Barış adı altında savaş çıkaranlar,
din adı altında dinsizlik yapanlar,
dürüst gözükmek için
bir şekilde dolap çevirenler,
bir sürü erdemli gözükme
çabası içerisinde
erdemsizlik yapanlarla
karşılaşabilirsiniz.
Bu anlamda bizim aslında
aşılanabilmemiz lazım,
yırnak içinde kötü olmaya.
Çünkü biz ne yaparsak yapalım
birileri bize iyi diyecek,
birileri kötü diyecek.
Bundan kaçınmayacağız
ve el alem ne der
ve ben kötü gözükmeyeyim
girdabından çıkamazsak eğer
etiketlerin kurbanı olacağız demektir.
Eğer aşılanabilirsek kötü olmaya,
belki o tırnak içindeki kötülük içinde
gerçekten ahlaklı olabileceğiz.
Çünkü akıllının işi bazen delisi olmaktır
bazı ortamların.
Hakperestin işi bazen inkarcısı
olmaktır batılın.
Bazen sapkını olmaktır yanlış yolun.
Bazen inananı olmaktır hurafe denilenin.
O yüzden bazen bir yerlerin
haini olmak zorundayız,
belki de kötüsü olmak zorundayız.
Sonuç olarak geçmiş hikayelerimizi
geleceğe zenginlik olarak
dönüştürmek istiyorsak eğer,
avcı değil sanatçı olmak zorundayız.
Çok meraklı ve biraz şüpheci
olmak zorundayız.
Nefretten biraz şefkate
uzanabilmek zorundayız.
Çünkü dönüştüren insanlar,
acılarını kabullenmekle birlikte
eritirler kendi içlerinde,
çiğneyerek yutarlar,
misafir ederek yolcularlar.
Dönüştürenler olmamız için:
Şimdi başımıza ne gelecekse gelecek.
Kaçınılmaz acılar var.
Ne yaşayacaksak yaşayacağız.
Onlar başımıza geldiğinde o kavşakta
seçim yapmamız gereken bir şey var.
Bir soruya iyi yanıt vermemiz gerekiyor:
Ey insan, başına ne olursa olsun
gelecek acılarda
yanacak mısın yoksa
pişecek misin kederinle?
Teşekkür ederim.